new developments overnight in the
aftermath of the violent assault on
capitol hill including
as anthony just said the death of a
police officer who responded to the
right
he was allegedly hit in the head with a
fire extinguisher
think about that for just a second five
people are now dead after a pro-trump
mob stormed the building
following a speech by the president
terrorizing those inside
and in most cases walking out without
being arrested
law enforcement are looking for dozens
of people who were involved as part of
an
investigation that could now include
homicide charges
jeff begays is on capitol hill he was
also there for the riot jeff what do we
know
well good morning a lot of the focus
this morning is on that fallen officer
who
died from injury sustained during that
violent riot i want you to take a look
at this real
really stirring image of police officers
gathered here at the capitol last night
flashing their lights in unison
as a show of respect capitol police says
it expresses its deepest sympathies to
officer brian sicknick's family and
friends on their loss
and mourns the loss of a friend and
colleague
the violent domestic terrorism seen on
capitol hill on wednesday
killed capitol police officer brian
sicknick a 12-year veteran who most
recently served in the department's
first responder unit
in a statement capitol police said
officer sicknick collapsed after a
confrontation with violent rioters
and his death is being investigated as a
possible homicide
cycnic's death comes hours after the u.s
capitol police chief
and house and senate sergeants at arms
stepped down after
outrage from the police union and both
sides of the aisle on wednesday's
security failures
they could have killed us all
they could destroy the government the
justice department
is investigating stolen electronic items
and documents possibly containing
sensitive national security information
thousands of national guard troops
deployed into washington overnight to
help secure the city
cbs news has learned that some of the
rioters involved in wednesday's attack
have remained in the area and new
intelligence shows that they may be
planning more attacks in the city
and on federal buildings a full manhunt
is on
as the fbi and d.c police search
airports and hotels for rioters who
ransacked the capitol
the fbi released this photo of a person
believed to be responsible for the pipe
bombs found in d.c on wednesday
offering a 50 thousand dollar reward for
any information
more than 50 people have already been
charged with crimes related to the
violence
including those with a semi-automatic
weapon and
11 molotov cocktails there are also
warning signs on social media that
inauguration day may be their next
target
a post on a white supremacist telegram
channel says
it is the next date on the calendar that
the pro trump and other
nationalist crowds will potentially
converge on the capitol again
this has kind of broken the veil of
protection here at the capitol
despite the hovering threats of the
inauguration
the inaugural committee is moving ahead
with the planning the secret service
tells us that they are
moving ahead with their security
planning for the event which is in just
12 days meanwhile as far as the
investigation into what happened here on
wednesday the fbi
says it has gotten about 4 000 tips
so far tony planning and preparation
always helps that's why we would have
liked to have seen it more on january 6.
jeff thank you very much